joining us now with the reaction as Fox
News contributor Herman Cain and Florida
congressman Matt Gaetz all right
congressman I'm gonna ask you first what
do you think of this new report by the
Intel committee the Republican majority
actually well this report is a decisive
win for the president because it
supports what the president has been
saying all along and that is that
Russians had a greater involvement in
the drafting of the Hillary Clinton
funded Christopher Steele author dossier
than they ever had with the Trump
campaign no evidence of collusion still
and frankly judge Jeanine this points
out the need to disband the Muller
investigation because it's built on a
rotten premise that has now been
disproven with 250 pages of fact all
right and Herman Cain to you what is
your take on this latest report from the
Intel committee my take judge Jeanine is
that he is not in hot water he lied and
lied and lied and now we have to wait
for the process to play itself out Comey
I'm talking about we now have to wait
for the process to play itself out for
him to end up end up in court such that
a court judgment proves that he lied and
tried to keep a cloud over this
administration he and others have tried
to keep a cloud over this administration
but with this report the clouds have
parted and now we're seeing the truth
and that's what the American people
wanted to see you know what's
interesting Herman is that even though
you say that you know we want to see the
courts get involved the truth is that
the inspector general's report was
supposed to come out in April regarding
Comey and now if they say May and
probably even later than that
Christopher's steal there was a
reference because he lied to the FBI I
believe was chairman Grassley's
committee who made a criminal referral
to the Department of Justice months and
months ago nothing's happened we knew
McCabe lied over more than several
months ago nothing's happened what do
you think it's gonna take I think
they're slow walking the documents so we
don't have the evidence so the American
people get past 2018
change change the house I absolutely
agree with you they are trying to slow
walk this cloud slow walk these
investigations such that they get
through November 2018 but here's the
thing judge Jeanine the American people
including some Democrats are not stupid
we've had enough evidence come out even
through the media that says he has lied
and discredited himself and they're not
going to swallow the gullible lies that
the Democrats and the Liberals are
trying to push on the American people
they won't be able to slow walk this one
because when that aging aging-- report
comes out it's gonna be the icing on the
cake all right in congressman gates you
know you ended by saying your last
comment that you know it's time for the
special counsel the Muellers a group to
be disbanded but today were yesterday I
believe it was chairman Grassley at the
Senate Judiciary who led a bill out of
committee supported by a few Democrat of
you Republicans like Lindsey Graham
saying they're going to block the
president from firing Muller in
disbanding the Commission I mean on the
one hand we've got you saying one thing
and then we've got grass he's saying now
that Y is Grassley wasting his time with
this kind of a bill
well senator Grassley has done a lot to
contribute to our investigation of the
FBI and their wrongdoing my concern is
that we have some Senate Republicans who
are more worried about protecting Bob
Muller than they are about protecting
the United States border in our
Constitution I wish the Senate would
take up the 500 bills the house is sent
over to advance the Trump agenda and to
restore constitutional principles
instead they're wasting time on this for
avala t the Constitution could not be
clearer the employees of the executive
branch worked for the president and he
can't fire them okay well there's no
question about that but I'm just gonna
go back to you congressman gates one of
the things that chairman Grassley
answered when I asked him that very
question house passing almost 500 bills
Senate doing virtually nothing he said
well you know we've got the filibuster
so I can't do anything unless I have
bipartisan support what do you say to
that they have the filibuster because
they want to have the filibuster you
know what judge Jeanine if some demo
crowd wants to filibuster one of the
president's appointees or meaningful
legislation let them take to the floor
the Senate and stand up and read the
phonebook or dr. Seuss and let the
American people see the absurdity that
is playing out in the Senate with
Democrats refusing to do their job and
take tough votes and you know what Mitch
McConnell's helping them because he
won't actually bring bills to the floor
and he empowers Chuck Schumer and the
Democrats far too much okay and Herman
Cain what do you say to that yeah what I
say to that is he is absolutely right
look memo to Senate you are not
president they're trying to micromanage
the president by telling him who he can
fire and not fire it's his decision and
they seem to forget this and this isn't
the first time that they have tried to
micromanage the decisions that this
president has the ability to make if he
wants to let him do his job
United States Senate Democrats and
Republicans and you know congressman
there's you know America is fed up with
Congress they have one of the lowest
approval ratings of anybody I mean I
can't think of anyone other than career
criminals who have lower approval
ratings but they're not doing anything
anyway this resistance is obstruction
here we are a year later and there's
nothing on Russia collusion nothing and
the Democrats keep saying it's coming
it's coming and we are wasting away the
ability to support this president
Republicans - what is their problem with
President Trump well your point is
accurate Congress has a 9% approval
rating I think moammar qaddafi had a 13%
approval rating in his own people
dragged him in the streets and killed
him so I think that we need to you know
get off our Duff's and actually get in
gear and engage in the president's
agenda and move it forward the American
people did not elect this president to
sit idly by and rearrange the deck
chairs on the Titanic we want a
disrupter someone who's going to change
the ways of Washington and frankly we
got too many swamp creatures in both
parties who just want to keep everything
the same and until we start embracing
this this disruptive agenda to make
things different inside the beltway I
feel the American people will still have
a negative
of our institution and and Herman cans
one last question I only have a few
seconds what do you think the Democrats
are going to come up with since most of
that the house Intel report by the
Republicans has been redacted I mean are
they going to come out with their own
report no they're gonna come up with
what they've always come up with deny
denial and distract those are the only
tax that they have and here's why just
Janine they you know TDS derangement
syndrome is no longer a medical disorder
it is a mental disease that's what
they're suffering from and they're gonna
continue to try to drag it out until
November all right Herman Cain
congressman gates thank you so much for
being with us tonight